hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry I'm
Andrew Andrew from movie source is
joining us rejects today for The Jungle
Book official Super Bowl trailer I'm
looking forward to this film it looks
good so far I saw the trailer on IMAX
holy [ __ ] is it look good on IMAX this
will be my first experience with any
jungle book trailer so I'm very curious
right you haven't seen any of the
trailers I'm like semi worried but very
curious I think the voice cast is
justing and also the fact that they shot
all this in LA it's like it's in crowd
yeah the whole thing is basically green
or blue screen to shut the whole thing
it's like a modern-day take of the
jungle but kept its head pit where they
replace all the animals just with
different kinds of deeds I mean in choke
a moon okay just listen just listen to
this jungle book but it's since at the
intersection Rudyard Kipling's it
scratched him if you can't learn to run
with the pack one of these days you'll
be someone's dinner
akan help but notice as the strange
older today man is forbidden
unbirthday
nice
the jungle is no longer safe for you but
this is my home
only man can protect you now Adam for
sweet little cub what are you doing so
deep in the jungle you have a man Cup
who wants to live in a job how do you
know that kid I got is my ears got ears
Oh
huh
forget about using Australian
that's a song about the good life
you will stop at nothing to because this
boy
if anything happens to that kid but we
never forgive myself
I'm working movie
come on Mowgli let's be on our way but
I'm helping blue get ready for
hibernation bears don't hibernate in a
jungle not full hibernation but i nap a
lot interesting can't you tell that was
all shot on blue screen Jerry I mean now
that you sampling that that looks that
looks a lot more like it likely looks a
lot better than I thought it would it
looks like a jungle book I like this
more yeah cuz like the idea of like
live-action or trying to be live-action
Jungle Book almost seems weird to me in
a Disney context but that looks like it
right especially one with talking
animals is just about this it managed to
pull it off for them but the only one I
looked a little off with Scarlett
Johansson was I'm like yeah I'm like
perfect cast for voice but something
just with the facts I don't know I might
look better when watching the actual
movie Brit looks a little bit off other
than that though I was watching like
Nate I think I could sit back and listen
to these animals talk to each other oh
yes if there's so much CGI like we must
have been incredibly expensive that's
what worries me sometimes is like when
you have these not that this is a
fantasy movie but when you have these
like really heavy lots of CG creatures
movies sometimes it can be a bit too
much and they're kind of hollow at the
end and this like even though sometimes
you can tell that these received
creatures something about it right now
looks very natural looks like it works
well it looks like they beyond just CG
characters it looks like the characters
have personality like I'm Christopher
Walken as Christopher Wan King Louie
yeah this point King Louie is like
nobody's perfectly guess you know like
oh yeah he has really good cat I hope
they do that song that they played in
The Jungle Book film they don't sing in
this trailer well we got to see the bare
necessities son but there's a song that
King Luke it's escaping me right now I
haven't watched the the animated film in
a long time going back to your point
about seeing talking animals this if you
guys remember back in 1994
we got a live-action take with the guy
who played Jason Scott Lee and as your
mind that was directed by Steven summers
as you remember we didn't get any
talking animals in that film so it was
you know as an interesting take but it
was you have no idea what the animals
are thinking obviously you go by their
actions you know what I mean but
cool now to get that and again the voice
cast is amazing it's great to actually
like we said I have her over people oh
yeah yeah I feel like these characters
are actually performances instead of
like you know sometimes you see animated
movies where they cast actors just so
they can put their name on the title I
feel like these actors were specifically
cast for these particular roles yeah
well and it's like it's who you would
want in a movie like this cuz this is
based on you know a classic novel and
stuff like that you know like that's
kind of where my hesitation comes from
is like I'm you have this beloved
animated movie based on a classic novel
and I'm sort of like please let this be
better than just the money machine and
it looks like there's a lot of genuine
crafting that went into Rise and also
two big feels like they did everything
the proper way and not just the money
way right and those from the outside and
also to their lat Disney's last film it
was Cinderella and that wasn't credit
for me personally I was incredible I'm
definitely curious to see what they do
in this obviously I didn't personally
care for Alice in Wonderland I didn't
think that was very good but you know
that was that's what I'm talking about
it's like everything is so CG and you're
like kind of beautiful but so much of it
starts to write you become aware after a
while I have more I personally have a
little more faith in Jon Favreau than
Tim Burton at this point but I'm very
curious to see what his take is gonna be
on this but it looks fun a friend of
mine I think sums it up is just CGI is
like the worst thing to happen to timbre
Jon Favreau I don't know and I'm you
know he brought personnel I do the Iron
Man movies oh yeah and there was Cowboys
versus aliens which I just heard was
kind of I love chef though that was
incredible and that's Jon Favreau doing
something independent that you can tell
he's really into so I just hope that
your big studio movies are stressful and
hard to make and I know there was a
friction on Iron Man I hope that this
'ready gets to have that love and not
the span hopefully after the success of
this one I'd love to see him do a Star
Wars film I don't want Jon Favreau to
get too carried away like I want him
plants to feel again carried away here
Jerry like it would be cool but I would
want him to feel I did it I'm glad they
cast a unknown for Mowgli yes you know
instead of like going loser who's a
child actor yeah yeah
exactly that's probably one for one and
he's in here the one like almost in that
area FBI guy that we're not gonna even
cast the proper wood so as cool that
they actually got like an unknown after
it makes you know if they're worried
about stardom that's all made up with
the animals and the voice actors I don't
know if it's motion capture actually
wouldn't be surprised now if like the
actors themselves didn't motion capture
like it wouldn't surprise me if there
was someone else to do the motion
capture than into the voices but that
would be cool if the actors themselves
did the motion capture they could be
very funny just to imagine like Bill
Murray and Bill Kingsley and a Juris
Elba and all these pictures hanging out
these like spandex with dots all over
them so I could see Christopher Walken
doing that I want the point now you just
said Bill Kingsley Ben Kingsley I'm so
sorry I was rallying among nad Oh Murray
Ben Kingsley last thing I want to say is
I hope this goes with the ending from
the novel do you know the difference
yeah I do okay in the novel Mowgli uh
you know in the ending of the cartoon
when Mowgli Ritter Khan goes with the
girl into the village and easily all
right but I want to take this bucket of
water with me so in then the book Mowgli
goes into the village the village ends
up rejecting him because they're like no
we can't accept you you're not one of us
and then a family takes them into hiding
they end up the village ins of finding
out kills the family Mowgli escapes
Mowgli then gathers a bunch of animals
and [ __ ] up everyone in that village
killing everyone are you sure that's the
actual and you guys should I might I
might have gotten like one or two things
slightly uh yeah I don't know if
Disney's gonna do no but I think dance
is so commit to the original source
material xenophobe I can do an and do
the Fox in the Hound real life where he
shoots copper to it'd definitely be a
twist ending I would not see coming
hey I mean these stories
no in order to make them make you feel
good you got a kind of water I'm gonna
be really not to say anything against
the Disney classrooms like every single
Disney movie is based on a story that is
much darker
well guys yeah that was a fun trailer
I'm definitely gonna be in the theaters
keep a lookout for our movie review of
that if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe today become a reject
because that's a cool title to have
sounds cool sounds like you're a rebel
you know fit in with me and wear a shirt
hashtag reject but I'm not coming up
with any design soon good reasons cherry
dank ass dubs on this channel movie
source channel starring Andrew and his
cousin check it out and Internet's not
working right now so I don't give a
shout out to a guy named Greg Alba Oh
Greg Alba um close friend of mine close
friend of mine and we're uh we're very
similar in a lot of ways we have our
differences some say he's nicer more
sincere a little bit more authentic um
less racist less sexist and he's good to
his girlfriend and I can tell you - I do
people say you know hey people say the
exact opposite about me fortunately him
and I are best friends yeah and I also -
Greg Alba does not get mine sabers
around Mesa that's a good feeling to
know ah
I am mine sabers just know that when I
get a mine saber oh wait those are
another gonna different video hey a
different video ops - whoever can go
find that video